Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In early 2000, 21-year-old Lucy Blackman and her long-time best friend Louise Phillips devised a plan to spend a few months living and working in Japan. The pair had lived seemingly parallel lives, with both working in an investment bank before commencing work as flight attendants for UK airline British Airways.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目简介。2000年初，21岁的露西·布莱克曼（Lucy Blackman）和她多年的挚友露易丝·菲利普斯（Louise Phillips）制定了一个计划，要在日本生活和工作几个月。这两个女孩的生活轨迹似乎平行，她们都曾在投资银行工作，之后又加入英国航空公司（British Airways）担任空姐。
Lucy's previous nine-to-five corporate job in London had left her bored and her expensive spending habits had led her into debt. She craved a life of adventure where she could travel internationally and experience different cultures, but couldn't afford to travel in style and the concept of backpacking held no appeal. In 1998, Lucy's impressive customer service on short-haul flights led to a promotion to the Intercontinental Circuit. Not only did her new role take her to exotic and glamorous destinations, she also received
露西之前在伦敦从事朝九晚五的白领工作，这让她感到厌烦，而她昂贵的消费习惯也让她背上了债务。她渴望过一种可以进行国际旅行并体验不同文化的高冒险生活，但她又负担不起豪华旅行，背包客的概念也对她没有任何吸引力。1998年，露西在短途航班上出色的客户服务表现为她赢得了晋升，她调入了洲际航线。她的新角色不仅带她去了充满异国情调和迷人的目的地，她还获得了
a healthy pay increase, with bonuses for longer flights and generous daily meal allowances. Despite these perks, the initial appeal of her jet-setting career quickly faded. Lucy soon found the job tiring and monotonous as her days became a blur of in-flight meals and generic hotel rooms. Her health began to decline as she was constantly jet-lagged and she had fallen further into debt by spending more money than she was earning. Her best friend Louise Phillips was equally disenfranchised and both women craved a new adventure.
可观的薪资增长，长途航班还有奖金以及慷慨的每日餐费补贴。尽管有这些福利，她这种经常飞来飞去的职业最初的吸引力很快就消退了。露西很快发现这份工作既疲惫又单调，她的日子成了一片模糊的机上餐食和千篇一律的酒店房间。她的健康状况开始下降，因为她经常有时差，而且由于花销超过了收入，她的债务越积越多。她的挚友露易丝·菲利普斯也同样感到幻灭，两个女人都渴望一次新的冒险。
Louise's older sister Emma had previously been on a working holiday to Japan where she was employed as a hostess. Although Lucy wasn't clear exactly what Emma's Japanese job had entailed, she knew it involved bars, waitressing and the potential to earn a lot of money. She became convinced hostessing presented a great opportunity to pay off her debts while seeing more of the world and decided to leave her job at British Airways to pursue the idea Lucy's family and friends were confused about her sudden decision to head overseas and by what exactly she planned to do in Japan.
露易丝的姐姐埃玛（Emma）之前曾在日本度过工作假期，当时她在那里做女招待。虽然露西不太清楚埃玛在日本的具体工作内容，但她知道这涉及到酒吧、招待服务以及赚大钱的潜力。她开始确信，做女招待是一个在饱览世界风光的同时还清债务的绝佳机会，于是她决定辞去英航的工作去追求这个想法。露西的家人和朋友对她突然决定出国以及她计划在日本做什么感到十分困惑。
Lucy's mother Jane had a particularly ominous feeling about the trip and even considered hiding Lucy's passport to prevent her daughter from leaving. Before she departed, Jane snuck a Guardian Angel card and healing crystals into Lucy's luggage for protection. Lucy was seemingly unfazed by the concerns of those close to her. In early 2000, she and Louise obtained 90-day tourist visas and departed for Japan, arriving in Tokyo on May 4. Neither spoke Japanese and they were quickly overwhelmed by the enormity of the foreign
露西的母亲简（Jane）对这次旅行有一种特别不祥的预感，甚至考虑藏起露西的护照以阻止女儿离开。在露西出发前，简偷偷把一张守护天使卡和几块治愈水晶塞进露西的行李中以求保佑。露西似乎对身边之人的担忧无动于衷。2000年初，她和露易丝获得了90天旅游签证并动身前往日本，于5月4日抵达东京。两人都不会说日语，很快就被这个巨大异国城市的
city. Prior to their arrival, Lucy and Louise had arranged accommodation through Louise's sister Emma, who was no longer living in Tokyo, but had booked a room for the girls through a friend. The room was in a Gaijin house, inexpensive hostel-style accommodation rented to foreigners, known for being cramped, dirty and unsanitary, with a constantly rotating roster of inhabitants. Sasaki House, the place Lucy and Louise were staying, was no exception. They quickly nicknamed their undesirable home away from home, the Shit House, and tried
庞大体量压得喘不过气来。在抵达之前，露西和露易丝通过露易丝的姐姐埃玛安排了住处，埃玛当时已经不在东京了，但通过一个朋友为两个女孩预订了一个房间。这个房间位于一栋“外人屋”（Gaijin house）里，这是一种租给外国人的廉价旅社式住所，以拥挤、肮脏和不卫生著称，里面的住客也总是川流不息。露西和露易丝居住的佐佐木住宅（Sasaki House）也不例外。她们很快就把这个不尽如人意的异国临时住所戏称为“屎屋”（Shit House），并试图
to beautify their small, dingy room. It wasn't long before Lucy and Louise headed straight to the world-famous party capital of Roppongi, a district popular with tourists and backpackers. The thriving entertainment district featured many social haunts and hangouts, with organized the Japanese crime syndicates the Yakuza, known to have a large presence in the area. Although efforts to clean up Roppongi's sleazy reputation were underway, when Lucy and Louise arrived, it was still very much a melting pot of sordid bars, nightclubs, strip clubs, massage parlours, and brothels.
美化她们那个狭小阴暗的房间。没过多久，露西和露易丝就直奔世界闻名的派对之都六本木，这是一个深受游客和背包客欢迎的地区。这个蓬勃发展的娱乐区有许多社交场所和聚会地点，据了解日本黑社会组织雅库扎（Yakuza）在该地区有很大的势力。尽管当时人们正在努力洗脱六本木藏污纳垢的名声，但当露西和露易丝到达时，这里依然是一个藏污纳垢的酒吧、夜总会、脱衣舞俱乐部、按摩院和妓院的大熔炉。
Within a few days of their arrival, a Japanese man approached the young women on the street and told them he could help them find jobs as hostesses. He introduced them to the manager of a hostess bar called Club Casablanca, where both Lucy and Louise were hired on the spot. Club Casablanca was an older, slightly run-down club, with nine other foreign hostesses working at the bar. The concept of what exactly hostessing entails is complex, but stems from the gaseous of the 17th century, highly skilled women trained in the arts of dancing, music, costume, conversation,
在她们抵达后的几天内，一个日本男子在街上接近了这两个年轻女子，并告诉她们他可以帮她们找到女招待的工作。他把她们带到了一家名为卡萨布兰卡俱乐部（Club Casablanca）的女招待酒吧的经理面前，露西和露易丝两人当场就被录用了。卡萨布兰卡俱乐部是一家较老、略显破旧的俱乐部，酒吧里还有其他九位外国女招待。女招待的工作内容究竟是什么，这是一个复杂的问题，但它源自17世纪的艺伎，那些接受过舞蹈、音乐、服饰、谈话等艺术培训的高技能女性，
and ceremonial tea service. The day hostessing isn't quite as sophisticated, but like the gaseous before them, a hostess's job is to entertain. Young women, many of whom are foreigners working illegally on tourist visas, are paid to smile while providing male clients with company, flattery, and often karaoke, while serving them drinks and snacks at over-inflated prices. Hostess bars are hugely common in Japan and are a popular way for the white-collar male workforce to entertain clients and relax.
以及茶道仪式。现代的女招待没有那么高雅，但就像前代的艺伎一样，女招待的工作就是取悦他人。年轻女性——其中许多是持旅游签证非法工作的外国人——获得报酬，一边对男客户微笑着提供陪伴、奉承，通常还有卡拉OK，一边以虚高的价格为他们提供饮料和小吃。女招待酒吧在日本非常普遍，是白领男性劳动力招待客户和放松身心的热门方式。
In the sleazier clubs of Roppongi, the hostessing service can also include stripping and sex acts, but this wasn't on the menu at Club Casablanca. There, the hostessers were expected to appear available for the clientele, but would lose their jobs if they ever crossed the line into providing sexual services. Regardless, the nature of the job meant conversation with intoxicated clientele often turned intimate and was degrading to the hostess' One former hostess described the work at Club Casablanca as follows. You say what the men want to hear and you be what they want you to be.
在六本木那些更为藏污纳垢的俱乐部里，女招待服务还可能包括脱衣舞和性行为，但这并不是卡萨布兰卡俱乐部的业务。在那里，女招待被要求在客户面前显得随和可亲，但如果她们越界提供性服务，就会失去工作。不管怎样，这份工作的性质意味着与醉酒客户的对话往往会变得亲密，这对女招待来说是一种人格贬低。一位前女招待这样描述在卡萨布兰卡俱乐部的工作：你说男人想听的话，你做他们想让你成为的人。
Sometimes you have to play psychologist. Other times men come in and totally just want to get drunk and party and want a girl to join them. Earning decent money was based on a hostess' ability to gain as many regulars as possible, in turn earning more money for the club owners. When clientele return to the club and exclusively request to see a certain woman, they pay extra for the privilege, resulting in a bonus for the hostess. Hostess can secure an extra bonus by organising a private dinner date with customers, known
有时候你得扮演心理学家。而另一些时候，男人进来完全只是想喝醉、开派对，并希望有个女孩加入他们。赚取可观的收入取决于女招待争取尽可能多常客的能力，这反过来又为俱乐部老板赚取了更多钱。当客户返回俱乐部并专门要求见某位特定女性时，他们要为这种特权支付额外费用，从而为女招待带来奖金。女招待可以通过组织与客户的私人晚餐约会（被称为
as Doe Hands. Although foreign visitors are not legally entitled to work on a tourist visa, it was known that Japanese authorities typically turned a blind eye to the act, something club managers often used as a bargaining chip for exploitation in terms of shifts and wages. As Lucien de la Huiz learned the ins and outs of the job, it quickly became clear that any hostess who didn't start accruing personal requests from regulars or arranging multiple Doe Hand dates per month would lose her job. Within her first two weeks at Club Casablanca, Luci gained a doting regular named Ken who
“同伴”（Dohan）约会）来获得额外的奖金。虽然外国游客在法律上无权凭旅游签证工作，但众所周知，日本当局通常对这种行为睁一只眼闭一只眼，俱乐部经理经常利用这一点作为讨价还价的筹码，在轮班和工资方面进行剥削。随着露西（Luci）逐渐摸清了这份工作的门道，情况很快变得明朗起来：任何不开始积累常客的个人点名或每月安排多次“同伴”约会的女招待都会失去工作。在卡萨布兰卡俱乐部的前两周内，露西赢得了名叫肯（Ken）的痴情常客，他
visited her most days, but the pressure to gain more private requests than Doe Hand weighed on her heavily and exacerbated her insecurities. She constantly compared herself to Luiz, who she felt was getting far more attention from clients and adjusting better to their increasingly hectic social life outside of work. Most nights after finishing at Casablanca, Luci and Luiz would descend into Roppongi's nightlife, dancing and drinking with other expats and travellers until the early hours. The cycle of working, partying and sleeping before doing it all again the next night began
几乎每天都来看她，但争取更多私人点名和“同伴”约会的压力对她来说重若千金，并加剧了她的不安全感。她不断地拿自己和露易丝（Luiz）作比较，她觉得露易丝从客户那里得到了更多的关注，并且能更好地适应她们在工作之外日益忙碌的社交生活。大多数夜晚，在卡萨布兰卡俱乐部下班后，露西和露易丝会融入六本木的夜生活，与其他的旅居者和游客一起跳舞喝酒，直到清晨。工作、派对和睡觉，然后第二天晚上重复这一切的循环开始
to exhaust Luci. The working holiday to pay off her debts wasn't coming together at all like she had planned, and the pressure to earn more at the club through bonuses was starting to become overwhelming. On May 26, 2000, after three weeks in Japan, Luci confessed her feelings in her diary, writing, I'm not coping well here, I can't pull myself out of this hole I've fallen into. I feel so ugly and fat and invisible in there, I constantly hate myself. I'm so fucking up to my neck in debt and so badly need to do well.
让露西筋疲力尽。用来还清债务的工作假期根本没有按她计划的那样进行，通过奖金在俱乐部赚取更多钱的压力开始变得让人难以承受。2000年5月26日，在日本待了三周后，露西在日记中吐露了自己的心声，她写道：“我在这里应付得不好，我无法把自己从陷入的这个洞里拉出来。我在那里觉得自己好丑、好胖、好隐形，我 constantemente 讨厌自己。我该死的负债累累，太需要做好了。”
But I'm a crap hostess. I'm so exhausted with feeling this shit and feeling so lonely. I sometimes really can't be bothered to wait and find out what happens. I just want to disappear. By the start of July, after two months in Japan, Luci was finally starting to feel more at ease with her new foreign life. She had recently began dating a young US Navy Marine stationed in Tokyo named Scott, and her spirits lifted as she began to fall head over heels.
“但我是个糟糕的女招待。我对这种糟糕的感觉和如此孤独感到筋疲力尽。有时我真的懒得去等著看会发生什么。我只想消失。”到7月初，在日本呆了两个月后，露西终于开始对她的新异国生活感到更加自在。她最近开始和一名驻东京的年轻美国海军陆战队员斯科特（Scott）约会，随着她深深坠入爱河，她的精神也振奋起来。
The improvement in her mood seemed to have a positive impact on her hostessing as she gained more regular clients at Club Casablanca and secured several more Dohan dates. She seemed to be in a far better place and was starting to become more comfortable. On the afternoon of Saturday, July 1, Luci received a call on the shared payphone at Sasaki House where her and Louise were still living. The call was from a customer she had a prearranged Dohan lunch date with, who was calling to advise he was running late and would ring back when he was ready to meet her at the train station.
她情绪的好转似乎对她的女招待工作产生了积极的影响，她在卡萨布兰卡俱乐部获得了更多的常客，并锁定了更多的“同伴”约会。她似乎处于一个好得多的状态，并开始变得更加舒适。7月1日星期六下午，露西在佐佐木住宅（Sasaki House，她和露易丝仍住在那里）共用的公用电话上接到了一个电话。这个电话来自一位她已经预先安排好“同伴”午餐约会的客户，他打电话来通知说他要迟到了，等他准备好在火车站与她会合时会再打过来。
A short while later, he called again to advise he was now 10 minutes away. Luci didn't mention the man's name or say where they were going for their date, but she was excited because the customer had promised to give her a mobile phone. She and Louise both had the night off from work, so they made a plan to meet up after Lucy's date later that evening. After making her way to send a guy a station to meet her date, Lucy called Louise from her unnamed customer's mobile phone at 5pm to let her know they were travelling to the seaside.
不久后，他又打电话通知说他现在还有10分钟就到。露西没有提这个男人的名字，也没有说他们约会要去哪里，但她很兴奋，因为客户曾承诺送她一部手机。她和露易丝当晚都不用上班，所以她们计划在露西当晚晚些时候的约会结束后见面。露西前往发送一个人的车站（注：应为Sengakuji Station泉岳寺站的误听/误翻）去见她的约会对象，并在下午5点用她那个未具名客户的手机给露易丝打电话，让她知道他们正前往海边。
She assured Louise she would still be home in time for their night out as planned. Just after 7pm, Louise received a second phone call from Lucy, advising she would be home within the hour. She was in good spirits, as this time she was calling from her new mobile phone gifted by her date, along with a bottle of champagne. Lucy then called her boyfriend Scott, but when there was no answer, she let the message advising she would meet up with him the following day. Two hours went by, and Lucy still hadn't returned home, causing Louise to become increasingly
她向露易丝保证，她仍会按计划及时回家参加她们的夜生活。刚过晚上7点，露易丝接到了露西的第二个电话，通知说她将在一个小时内回家。她情绪很好，因为这次她是打自她的约会对象送她的新手机，还带着一瓶香槟。露西随后给她的男友斯科特打电话，但无人接听，于是她留下了语音留言，说她会在第二天和他见面。两个小时过去了，露西仍未回家，这让露易丝越来越
worried. She went to Club Casablanca to report her concerns to co-workers, but they suggested that Lucy had simply decided to stay the night with her customer. Louise felt strongly that her friend would never do such a thing, so she had a Japanese speaking co-worker call around to some of the bigger hospitals in the area to check if anyone matching Louise's description had been admitted, but there had been no sign of her. Before going to sleep, Louise spent the night wandering around Roppongi, visiting the clubs and bars that she and Lucy frequented to ask if anyone had seen her friend.
担忧。她去卡萨布兰卡俱乐部向同事报告了她的担忧，但他们暗示露西只是决定和她的客户过夜。露易丝坚信她的朋友绝不会做出这种事，于是她让一个会说日语的同事打电话给该地区的一些大医院，检查是否有符合露易丝描述特征的人入院，但没有她的任何踪迹。在睡觉前，露易丝花了一晚上的时间在六本木闲逛，走访她和露西常去的俱乐部和酒吧，打听是否有人见过她的朋友。
No one had. Anxious about their illegal working status, Louise hesitated about going to the police, despite growing more and more panicked. Lucy didn't return home or make contact during the remainder of the weekend. By the morning of Monday, July 3, Louise, who was so stressed she had barely slept, finally filed a missing person report with the Azabu police station in Roppongi. She didn't mention that Lucy had been working as a hostess and was attending a dohand date, instead saying she had simply gone out on a day trip with a Japanese man she had met.
没有人见过。由于担心她们非法的打工身份，露易丝在犹豫是否要报警，尽管她内心越来越恐慌。在接下来的周末里，露西没有回家，也没有与任何人联系。到了7月3日星期一早晨，露易丝压力大到几乎没合眼，终于在六本木的麻布警察署（Azabu police station）报案称有人失踪。她没有提到露西一直在做女招待并正在参加“同伴”约会，而是说她只是和她刚认识的一个日本男人出去进行了一日游。
The police didn't seem overly concerned about the missing Westerner. After all, Lucy was an independent adult who may have decided to continue travelling and had simply failed to notify anyone. Dishartened by the lack of action, Louise then went to the British Embassy in Tokyo and admitted the whole truth, telling the Vice Consul about Lucy's illegal hostessing work and the fact she had gone to meet a customer on the day she was last seen. The Embassy official was alarmed that the club would encourage such outings. The Vice Consul called Azabu police station to advise the Embassy was extremely concerned
警方似乎对这个失踪的西方人并不怎么关心。毕竟，露西是一个独立的成年人，可能决定继续旅行而只是没有通知任何人。面对不作为而感到沮丧，露易丝随后前往位于东京的英国大使馆并坦白了全部真相，向副总领事讲述了露西非法的女招待工作以及她在失踪当天去见了一位客户的事实。大使馆官员对俱乐部鼓励这种郊游的行为感到震惊。副总领事致电麻布警察署，通知大使馆极其关注
about Lucy's well-being, but despite telling police they feared Lucy had been abducted, the police still didn't seem overly concerned. At approximately 5.30pm that afternoon, Louise received a phone call on her mobile phone from an unknown man with a strong Japanese accent and a good command of English. The caller, who identified himself as Akira Takagi, said he was calling on behalf of Lucy. He told Louise that the traffic had been bad on the night Lucy went missing, so she decided to take the train home instead of accepting a ride with her date. At the train station, she met a guru and on the spur of the moment decided to join his
露西的安危，但尽管告诉警方他们担心露西遭到绑架，警方似乎依然没有表现出过多的关心。当天下午5点30分左右，露易丝的手机上接到一个陌生男子的来电，对方带有浓重的日本口音，英语说得很好。这名自称是高木明（Akira Takagi）的来电者说他是代表露西打来的。他告诉露易丝，露西失踪当晚交通很糟糕，所以她决定坐火车回家，而不是接受约会对象的车。在火车站，她遇到了一位大师，并临时起意决定加入他的
cult, the newly risen religion in the city of Chiba. Bewildered, Louise asked to speak to Lucy, but Akira said she wasn't feeling well and didn't want to talk to anyone, although she might want to talk later in the week. He hung up abruptly, but called back moments later, explaining that Lucy had started a new life and wouldn't be coming back. He said she was now paying her debts back in a better way and wanted her friends to know she was okay. Akira then asked Louise for her address in Japan as he needed to send some of Lucy's
邪教，即城市千叶的新兴宗教。迷惑不解的露易丝要求和露西通话，但明（Akira）说她身体不舒服，不想和任何人说话，尽管她可能会在周晚些时候想谈谈。他生硬地挂断了电话，但在片刻后又回了电话，解释说露西已经开始了新的生活，不会回来了。他说她现在正在以一种更好的方式偿还债务，并希望她的朋友们知道她很好。明随后向露易丝索要她在日本的地址，因为他需要把露西的一些
belongings back. Louise evaded this request and in a bid to gain more information, asked if she too could join the cult. She pleaded to speak to Lucy, but Akira rendered the call, stating, I'm sorry, I just had to let you know that you won't be seeing her again. Goodbye. Terrified, Louise returned to the British Embassy where she was advised to go back to the police station and admit the whole truth about what Lucy had been doing when she vanished.
私人物品寄回。露易丝避开了这个要求，为了获取更多信息，她问自己是否也能加入这个邪教。她恳求和露西通话，但明挂断了电话，并说：“很抱歉，我只是不得不让你知道你不会再见到她了。再见。”惊恐万分的露易丝返回英国大使馆，馆方建议她回到警察署，并坦白露西失踪时究竟在做什么的全部真相。
Later that same night, a teary and distressed Louise finally worked up the courage to call Lucy's family in England to advise them of her disappearance. Lucy's mother, Jane Stier, had been preparing a care package to send to Japan, containing some of her daughter's favorite sweets and cosmetics when she answered the call. As she began to absorb the bizarre news that Lucy was missing and had allegedly joined a Japanese cult, a group of Lucy's friends and her two younger siblings, sister Sophie and brother Rupert, gathered at Jane's home to offer their support and figure out what to do next.
就在当晚，情绪崩溃、悲痛欲绝的露易丝终于鼓起勇气给远在英国的露西家人打电话，告知他们她失踪的消息。露西的母亲简·斯蒂尔（Jane Stier）当时正在准备一个寄往日本的爱心包裹，里面装着她女儿最喜欢的糖果和化妆品，这时她接听了电话。当她开始消化露西失踪并据称加入了日本邪教这一离奇消息时，露西的一群朋友以及她的两个年幼弟弟妹妹（姐姐索菲和弟弟鲁珀特）聚集在简的家中，向她提供支持并商讨下一步该怎么做。
Louise's father, Tim Blackman, who had not spoken to his ex-wife since their divorce several years earlier, was also notified. Those close to Lucy were certain the story that she had joined a cult was a complete fabrication. They feared she had met with foul play. Lucy's 20-year-old sister Sophie and ex-boyfriend Jamie decided to fly to Tokyo immediately to begin searching for her. Louise's mother, Jane, didn't want to leave her teenage son Rupert alone in the UK, so she made the tough decision to stay at home.
露易丝的父亲蒂姆·布莱克曼（Tim Blackman，他在数年前离婚后就再也没有跟前妻说过话）也得到了通知。那些与露西亲近的人确信，她加入了邪教的说法完全是捏造的。他们担心她遭遇了不测。露西20岁的妹妹索菲和前男友杰米（Jamie）决定立即飞往东京开始寻找她。露易丝的母亲简不想把十几岁的儿子鲁珀特独自留在英国，于是她做出了留在国内的艰难决定。
On July 4, three days since Lucy had failed to return from her Dohan date, Sophie and Jamie departed for Tokyo, where they spent a week paying multiple visits to the British Embassy and to the Asabu police station in Roppongi. None of the visits proved helpful, as the police treated their concerns with the same indifference they had shown Louise. Faced with the inaction of local police, Sophie spoke with her father Tim Blackman in the UK and discussed going public with Lucy's story and enlisting the help of the media to gain interest and help for her disappearance.
7月4日，即露西未能从“同伴”约会中归来的三天后，索菲和杰米动身前往东京，在那里他们花了一周时间多次访问英国大使馆和六本木的麻布警察署。每一次访问都毫无用助，因为警方对待他们担忧的态度和之前对待露易丝时一样冷漠。面对当地警方的不作为，索菲与身在英国的父亲蒂姆·布莱克曼进行了交谈，并讨论了将露西的故事公之于众，以及借助媒体的力量来引起关注并为寻找她的失踪提供帮助。
Although they all held concerns that going public may have an adverse impact and cause Lucy's abductor to panic and harm or kill her. In the end, the decision was made for them, as back in London, Louise's sister Emma Phillips had already taken the story to British newspaper The Daily Telegraph. With the media now notified, Lucy's disappearance was quickly plastered throughout UK papers. Despite the public attention, Tokyo police continued to show little interest in pursuing an investigation. Frustrated, the Blackman family decided to embrace the media attention towards fullest,
尽管他们都担心公开可能会产生负面影响，并导致绑架露西的人惊慌失措而伤害或杀死她。最终，这个决定由不得他们了，因为在伦敦，露易丝的姐姐埃玛·菲利普斯已经将这个故事爆料给了英国报纸《每日电讯报》（The Daily Telegraph）。随着媒体的介入，露西失踪的消息迅速登上了英国各大报纸。尽管受到了公众的关注，东京警方仍然对推进调查表现出极小的兴趣。沮丧之余，布莱克曼一家决定充分利用媒体的关注，
in the hopes their efforts would compel someone with information to come forward. On July 12, 11 days into Lucy's disappearance, her father Tim Blackman made the overseas journey to join the search and raise media awareness. The next day, Tim and his daughter Sophie held their first press conference at the British Embassy in Tokyo, imploring anyone who had seen Lucy to contact police. Reports that Lucy suddenly abandoned her life to join a cult seemed unlikely to her family, as she had never demonstrated much interest in religion. They also rejected claims she may have run away to escape her credit card debt, describing
希望他们的努力能促使掌握信息的人站出来。7月12日，在露西失踪11天后，她的父亲蒂姆·布莱克曼跨海来到日本加入搜寻并提高媒体知名度。第二天，蒂姆和女儿索菲在东京英国大使馆召开了第一次新闻发布会，恳求任何见过露西的人联系警方。露西突然放弃生活去加入邪教的报道在她的家人看来似乎不太可能，因为她从未表现出对宗教有多大兴趣。他们还驳斥了她可能为逃避信用卡债务而逃跑的说法，称
the amount of money she owed as manageable. During a subsequent press conference, Tim issued a passionate plea to Lucy's abductor to release his daughter. We are all starting to feel very desperate and upset that Lucy is kept somewhere in difficult conditions where she will be extremely upset herself. I therefore, as her father, beg of them humbly to please just release her to us again. I just can't begin to describe to this person or these people the devastating sorrow we have been through and how we are being torn apart by Lucy being held away from us.
她欠下的金额是在可控范围内的。在随后的新闻发布会上，蒂姆向露西的绑架者发出了一声充满悲情与恳求的呼吁，要求释放他的女儿。“我们大家开始感到非常绝望和心烦意乱，因为露西被关在某个条件恶劣的地方，她自己也会极其痛苦。因此，我作为她的父亲，卑微地乞求他们请把她再次释放给我们。我无法向这个人或这些人形容我们经历的毁灭性悲伤，以及露西被隔离在外正将我们撕裂。”
After this emotional display, media interest in the story intensified, and British reporters arrived to Japan in droves to interview Tim and Sophie, the father and daughter appearing on multiple TV shows in both the UK and Japan. With the increased media attention putting pressure on the police to act, the Tokyo Metropolitan police upgraded Lucy's disappearance to a criminal investigation. While out to dinner one night, Tim and Sophie Blackman were approached by a wealthy British expat named Hugh Shakeshaft, who recognised them from their many media appearances as he had been following Lucy's disappearance closely.
在这番情感流露之后，媒体对该事件的兴趣更加浓厚，英国记者蜂拥至日本采访蒂姆和索菲，这对父女出现在英国和日本的多档电视节目中。随着媒体关注度的提高对警方构成了行动压力，东京警视厅将露西的失踪升级为刑事案件。一天晚上外出用餐时，蒂姆和索菲·布莱克曼遇到了一位富有的英国旅居者休·谢克斯哈夫特（Hugh Shakeshaft），他在许多媒体报道中认出了他们，因为他一直在密切关注露西的失踪。
Hugh generously donated a £100,000 reward for information and offered the Blackman's the use of his business officers in Roppongi as their operational base. Tim and Sophie used this opportunity to set up the Lucy Blackman hotline, where people who were hesitant about going to the police could call in with information. Offers of assistance poured in from the UK, with the Virgin Atlantic airline conglomerate financing the advertisement of the hotline number. Police found out Sir Richard Branson also offered financial assistance in the search. The hotline, which was stuffed by expats, began operation 21 days into the search for Lucy.
休慷慨地捐赠了10万英镑作为提供线索的悬赏金，并向布莱克曼一家提供他在六本木的商务办公室作为他们的行动基地。蒂姆和索菲利用这个机会设立了露西·布莱克曼热线，那些对直接报警有所顾虑的人可以打电话提供信息。来自英国的援助如潮水般涌来，维珍航空（Virgin Atlantic）集团资助了热线号码的广告宣传。警方发现理查德·布兰森爵士（Sir Richard Branson）也在搜寻工作中提供了财政援助。由旅居者担任接线员的热线在搜寻露西21天后开始运作。
Calls came flooding in, with many witnesses reporting seeing the missing 21-year-old, but they had simply mistaken other blonde Western women for Lucy. The answering machine for the hotline also reported many bizarre messages, including laughter, strange rants and incoherent mumbling. Police interviewed Lucy's US Marine boyfriend Scott as a person of interest, but he had been aboard a naval ship on the day of her disappearance. Lucy's regular customer at Club Casablanca, Cannes, was also interviewed, but he too was eliminated as a suspect.
电话如潮水般涌入，许多目击者报告说看到了失踪的21岁女孩，但他们只是把其他金发西方女性误认成了露西。热线的答录机还记录了许多离奇的留言，包括笑声、奇怪的胡言乱语和语无伦次的喃喃自语。警方将露西的美国海军陆战队男友斯科特作为重点嫌疑人进行了讯问，但他在她失踪当天一直在海军舰艇上。卡萨布兰卡俱乐部的常客肯也被讯问，但他也作为嫌疑人被排除了。
In July 21 and 23, the 26th annual G8 summit was held on the Japanese island of Okinawa, where world leaders from eight different countries, including the United Kingdom and Japan, came together to discuss a range of global issues. Prior to the G8 summit, British Prime Minister Tony Blair agreed to meet with Tim Blackman to discuss Lucy's disappearance and gain an understanding of the issues the family were facing in their efforts to find her. This conversation prompted Tony Blair to discuss the case directly with Japanese Prime Minister Yoshiro Mori, which propelled the Tokyo Metropolitan Police into further action.
7月21日至23日，第26届G8峰会在日本冲绳岛举行，来自英国和日本等八个不同国家的领导人齐聚一堂，讨论了一系列全球议题。在G8峰会之前，英国首相托尼·布莱尔同意与蒂姆·布莱克曼会面，讨论露西的失踪问题，并了解该家庭在努力寻找她时所面临的问题。这次谈话促使托尼·布莱尔直接与日本首相森喜朗讨论了此案，这推动东京警视厅采取了进一步行动。
A large number of detectives were assigned to the case, and 30,000 missing person posters featuring a photograph of Lucy sitting on a sofa wearing a black dress were distributed throughout Japan. The poster used bilingual text in both Japanese and English to describe the 21-year-old, and urged anyone who had seen Lucy or had any information to contact their nearest police station. A police spokesperson told the media, quote, We are involved in a very difficult investigation since we have yet to obtain a single tip that
大量侦探被指派负责此案，3万张印有露西坐在沙发上穿着黑色连衣裙照片的失踪人口海报在日本各地分发。海报采用日文和英文的双语文字来描述这位21岁的女孩，并敦促任何见过露西或有任何信息的人联系他们最近的警察署。一名警方发言人告诉媒体：“我们正参与一项非常困难的调查，因为我们尚未获得任何能
has led us to a major breakthrough. Tim and Sophie, with assistance from generous volunteers, walked the streets of Tokyo handing out the missing person flyers, urging passers-by to come forward with any information. On August 1, one month after Lucy's disappearance, Tokyo police received a typed letter allegedly written by the missing 21-year-old. The letter insisted she was fine, urging her family not to worry and to return to England where she would call them later. However, it appeared that whoever wrote the letter was not a native English speaker, as
引领我们取得重大突破的线索。”蒂姆和索菲在慷慨的志愿者的协助下，走上东京街头分发失踪人员传单，敦促路人挺身而出提供任何信息。8月1日，即露西失踪一个月后，东京警方收到了一封据称由失踪的21岁女孩所写的打印信件。信中坚称她很好，敦促家人不要担心并返回英国，她随后会打电话给他们。然而，写这封信的人似乎并不是母语为英语的人，因为
it was filled with all kinds of linguistic and grammatical errors, with police promptly dismissing it as a hoax. On August 4, an exhausted Tim Blackman returned home to the United Kingdom, leaving Sophie in Japan to continue the search for her sister. Despite police increasing their efforts, they continued to leave Lucy's family in the dark about any progress in the investigation. Soon after Tim arrived home, he received a startling phone call from a British man named Mike Hills who lived in Holland and claimed to have contacts in the Japanese underworld.
里面充满了各种语言和语法错误，警方迅速将其作为恶作剧不予理睬。8月4日，筋疲力尽的蒂姆·布莱克曼返回英国，留下索菲在日本继续寻找她的姐姐。尽管警方加大了搜寻力度，但他们仍然对调查的任何进展对露西的家人秘而不宣。蒂姆刚回到家不久，就接到了一位住在荷兰、自称在日本黑社会有人脉的英国男子迈克·希尔斯（Mike Hills）打来的惊人电话。
Mike said these figures had a vested interest in finding Lucy, as the resulting police pressure was impacting arms dealers and other Yakuza members from effectively conducting their unlawful business. To ensure their dealings resumed to normal, these gang members were willing to try and find Lucy, but their assistance came with a price. Tim arranged to meet with Mike Hills, but before the meeting, Mike called back with the news that one of his contacts had discovered Lucy was alive. She had been kidnapped and sold by a group involved in the trafficking of foreign women.
迈克说，这些人物在寻找露西一事上有着既得利益，因为由此产生的警方压力正在影响军火商和其他雅库扎成员合法开展非法生意的能力。为了确保他们的交易恢复正常，这些帮派成员愿意试着寻找露西，但他们的协助是有代价的。蒂姆安排与迈克·希尔斯见面，但在会面之前，迈克回电带来了一个消息：他的人脉之一发现露西还活着。她被一个涉及贩卖外国女性的团伙绑架并卖掉了。
This contact could find Lucy and buy her back for the price of $50,000. Tim was deeply unsure about Mike's claim, but was willing to take any chance to find his daughter. The two men met, and Mike explained that Tim would have to make an on-the-spot payment of $12,500 to secure the deal. He would then need to travel to Japan to hand over an additional $25,000, followed by a final payment of $12,500 to be paid once Lucy was safely returned. Tim paid the $12,500 in cash as instructed, and quickly made his way back to Japan.
这个人可以找到露西并以5万美元的价格把她买回来。蒂姆对迈克的说法深表怀疑，但为了找到女儿，他愿意抓住任何机会。两人见面后，迈克解释说蒂姆必须当场支付1.25万美元以敲定交易。然后他需要前往日本交出额外的2.5万美元，并在露西安全归还后支付最后一笔1.25万美元的尾款。蒂姆按指示支付了1.25万美元现金，并迅速启程返回日本。
Upon his arrival, Mike's story took a turn. Lucy was no longer in Japan, but had been smuggled out on a ship and was on her way to Hong Kong. The ship could be intercepted, but it would require an additional payment of $10,000. Desperate to save Lucy, Tim handed over the money. Following this transaction, Mike's story constantly changed. He continued to ask for more money, despite seeming to be no closer to retrieving Lucy. Eventually, the calls from Mike Hills stopped entirely, and Tim was unable to contact him,
在他抵达后，迈克的说法发生了转变。露西已经不在日本了，而是被用船走私出去，正在去香港的路上。这艘船可以被拦截，但这需要额外支付1万元。急于拯救露西的蒂姆交出了这笔钱。在这笔交易之后，迈克的说法不断改变。他继续索要更多钱，尽管看起来离找回露西并没有更近一步。最终，来自迈克·希尔斯的电话完全停止了，蒂姆无法联系到他，
leading to the stark realization that the vulnerable father had been conned. Tim reported his experience to police, who discovered Mike Hills had an extensive criminal history for deception and theft, having also scammed another English family whose son had gone missing in South America. For his lies to both families, Mike Hills was later charged with obtaining property by deception and sentenced to three and a half years in prison. Of the scam, Tim Blackman later said, It produced a huge strain on our family.
这导致这位脆弱的父亲痛苦地意识到自己被骗了。蒂姆向警方报案，警方发现迈克·希尔斯有着漫长的欺诈和盗窃前科，他还曾诈骗过另一个在南美失踪的英国男孩的家庭。由于对两个家庭的谎言，迈克·希尔斯后来被控以欺诈手段获取财产罪，并被判处三年半监禁。谈到这场骗局时，蒂姆·布莱克曼后来表示：“它给我们的家庭带来了巨大的压力。”
It was a terrible, terrible thing that he perpetrated on us. He is absolutely evil. He was preying on our family's misfortune, and you cannot get more evil than that. Throughout August, Tim and Sophie Blackman continued to travel back and forth between Japan and the UK, manning the hotline and spending time in the hostess bars of Roppongi, seeking any information that might lead them to Lucy. The dark side of Japan's hostessing industry soon came to light, as they heard many harrowing stories of foreign hostesses who had gone missing or experienced violence at the hands of customers.
这是他对我们犯下的可怕至极的事情。他绝对是个恶魔。他在捕食我们家庭的不幸，再也没有比这更邪恶的了。整个8月，蒂姆和索菲·布莱克曼继续在日本和英国之间往返，值守热线并在六本木的女招待酒吧里度过时间，寻找任何可能指引他们找到露西的信息。日本女招待行业的黑暗面很快浮出水面，因为他们听到了许多关于外国女招待失踪或遭受客户暴力的凄惨故事。
Three years prior to Lucy's disappearance, 27-year-old Canadian hostess Tiffany Fordham disappeared after she was last seen with a customer in the elevator of a Roppongi nightclub. She was never seen again, with police conducting no efforts to find her. Other foreign hostesses reported incidents where customers had taken advantage of them during do-hand dates, with reports of drink spiking, violence and rape. As most hostesses were working illegally, a majority of these incidents were not reported to police, and to the ones that were, were rarely taken seriously. September 1 marked two months since Lucy Blackman left for her do-hand date and had
在露西失踪三年前，27岁的加拿大女招待蒂芬妮·福德姆（Tiffany Fordham）在最后一次被看到与一名客户一起进入六本木一家夜总会的电梯后失踪了。她再也没有被找到，警方也没有做出任何努力去寻找她。其他外国女招待报告说，她们在“同伴”约会期间遭到客户利用，并有被下药、遭遇暴力和强奸的报告。由于大多数女招待都是非法打工，其中绝大多数事件都没有向警方报案，而那些报了案的也很少被严肃对待。9月1日标志着露西·布莱克曼出发去参加“同伴”约会却
never returned. Back in the UK, her mother Jane and younger brother Rupert released 1,000 balloons over the cricket ground of Lucy's hometown to commemorate her 22nd birthday. As the month wore on, Lucy's family became increasingly despondent. They boosted the reward money for information in an attempt to generate new leads. But all this did was increase the number of false sightings placed to the hotline. Despite all their efforts, nobody seemed to have any information about Lucy's last movements or her whereabouts.
再也没有回来已经过去两个月了。远在英国的母亲简和弟弟鲁珀特在露西家乡的板球场上放飞了1000个气球，以纪念她的22岁生日。随着时间的推移，露西的家人变得越来越沮丧。他们提高了提供线索的悬赏金，试图发掘新的线索。但这一切所做的只是增加了打到热线上的虚假目击情报数量。尽管他们付出了种种努力，但似乎没有人知道关于露西最后的行踪或下落的任何信息。
Tensions began to rise between the Blackmans and Tokyo police, who insisted technical difficulties and complicated laws regarding the disclosure of private information was stopping them from obtaining phone records from the caller who rang Louise on July 3, advising that Lucy had spontaneously joined a cult. They eventually said they were obtaining a court order to gain access to the records, but advised Lucy's family to be patient as it would take some time. In late September, Lucy's mother Jane travelled to Tokyo and gave a press conference in which she implored Lucy's captor to release her daughter and to beg anyone with information
布莱克曼一家与东京警察之间的紧张关系开始升温，警方坚称技术困难以及关于披露私人信息的复杂法律阻止了他们从7月3日致电露易丝、声称露西是自发加入邪教的来电者那里获取通话记录。他们最终表示正在申请法院命令以获取这些记录，但建议露西的家人保持耐心，因为这需要一些时间。9月下旬，露西的母亲简前往东京并举行了一场新闻发布会，她在会上恳求露西的绑架者释放她的女儿，并恳求任何有线索的人
to come forward, stating, It's the worst nightmare and it never goes away. I feel as if my heart has been ripped out. As a family, we will never give up looking for Lucy and we will never take a no for an answer. By early October, Lucy's family were overwhelmed with all kinds of challenges. The makeshift operations centre at the offices provided by Hugh Shadeshaft had fallen apart, as Hugh felt Tim Blackman had abused his hospitality by disrespecting his staff, ordering expensive
站出来，并表示：“这是最可怕的噩梦，而且永远不会过去。我觉得我的心被挖出来了。作为一家人，我们永远不会放弃寻找露西，我们也绝不会接受‘不’这个答案。”到10月初，露西的家人被各种各样的挑战压得喘不过气来。休·谢克斯哈夫特提供的办公室里的临时行动中心已经解散，因为休觉得蒂姆·布莱克曼滥用了他的热情好客，对他的员工不尊重，在他的账单上订购昂贵的
dinners on his tab and constantly inviting members of the media into the office for interviews, despite specifically being asked not to. The relationship between Lucy's parents was also under strain and their visits to Japan were strategically timed to avoid one another. This discord between the divorced couple spilled out during media interviews, putting increased stress on the family. Having spent tens of thousands of pounds flying back and forth between Japan and the United Kingdom, they were also burdened with financial pressure.
晚餐，并且尽管被明确要求不要这样做，却不断邀请媒体成员到办公室进行采访。露西父母之间的关系也承受着压力，他们访问日本的时间经过了精心安排，以避免碰面。这对离异夫妇之间的这种不和在接受媒体采访时爆发了，给这个家庭带来了更大的压力。由于花费了数万英镑在日本和英国之间飞来飞去，他们还背负着沉重的经济压力。
Exhausted and tired of feeling like the Tokyo police were intentionally shutting them out, Lucy's mother, father and sister felt they had hit a brick wall in their efforts. Reluctantly, they each departed Japan and returned home. But unbeknownst to the family, their heavy media presence had actually paid off. Two witnesses had come forward to police offering information. One of the witnesses who came forward was an American woman who had been working as a hostess in Roppongi in 1997. As part of her duties, she agreed to visit a customer named Koji at the Zushi Marina
精疲力竭、厌倦了感觉东京警察故意将他们拒之门外的露西母亲、父亲和妹妹觉得他们在努力寻找的过程中撞上了一堵南墙。他们勉强各自离开日本返回家中。但出乎家人意料的是，他们强烈的媒体曝光度实际上得到了回报。两名目击者挺身而出向警方提供线索。其中一位站出来的目击者是一名美国女子，她曾于1997年在六本木做过女招待。作为职责的一部分，她同意拜访一位名叫孝治（Koji）的客户，地点位于
apartment complex in the seaside town of Zushi, located an hour's train ride from Tokyo. After taking a sip of a drink Koji offered to her, the woman blacked out and awoke sick on the couch many hours later wearing nothing but her underwear, with no memory of anything that had happened. Koji explained there had been a gas leak which had caused her to lose consciousness, but the woman suspected she had been drugged. She reported the incident to the Azabu police station with help from her employer, providing a description of Koji's appearance, the location of his apartment and his mobile phone number.
距离东京一小时火车车程的海滨小镇逗子（Zushi）的逗子码头公寓大楼。在喝了一口孝治递给她的饮料后，该女子失去了意识，许多小时后醒来时生病躺在沙发上，身上只穿着内衣，对发生过的一切毫无记忆。孝治解释说是发生了天然气泄漏才导致她失去知觉，但该女子怀疑自己被下药了。她在雇主的帮助下向麻布警察署报案，提供了孝治的外貌描述、公寓位置以及他的手机号码。
But her report was met with indifference. She later described her ordeal in Richard Lloyd Perry's book, People Who Eat Darkness. Quote, The officers showed no interest whatsoever to help or take any further action. They said they could not investigate my incident because of a lack of evidence. I was made to feel as if I were a nuisance and to wasting police time. Three years later, the woman was still living in Tokyo when she heard about Lucy Blackman's disappearance.
但她的报案遭到了冷遇。她后来在理查德·劳埃德·佩里（Richard Lloyd Perry）的书《吃黑暗的人》（People Who Eat Darkness）中描述了自己的悲惨遭遇。原话是：“警官们对帮忙或采取进一步行动没有表现出丝毫兴趣。他们说由于缺乏证据，他们无法调查我的事件。我感觉自己像个讨厌鬼，在浪费警方的宝贵时间。”三年后，这名女子仍住在东京，当时她听说了露西·布莱克曼失踪的消息。
Reminded of her ordeal in sushi years earlier, she immediately returned to the Azabu police station to report concerns that the same man who attacked her could be the customer Lucy had visited on the day she vanished. The American woman wasn't the only former hostess who provided police with information. In 1995, a Scottish expat went on a series of extravagant Dohan dates with a wealthy customer who called himself a Yuji Honda. One night, Yuji took his hostess to his seaside apartment where he asked her to drink a rare wine.
回想起多年前在逗子的悲惨遭遇，她立即回到麻布警察署，报告她担心袭击她的同一个男子可能就是露西在失踪当天拜访过的客户。这名美国女子并不是唯一向警方提供线索的前女招待。1995年，一名苏格兰旅居者与一位自称本多裕二（Yuji Honda）的富有客户进行了一系列穷奢极欲的“同伴”约会。一天晚上，裕二把他的女招待带到他的海滨公寓，在那里他请她喝了一杯稀有的葡萄酒。
More than 12 hours later, she awoke in his apartment with no memory of what had happened. She decided not to report the incident to police, but held on to Yuji's mobile phone number just in case. Five years later, when this woman heard about Lucy Blackman's disappearance, she travelled from her home in Osaka to the Azabu police station to report her concerns that the man she knew as Yuji Honda could be involved. Although she felt her statement was met with disinterest, several other hostesses also came forward to report similar experiences, ensuring police could no longer ignore the similarities
between witness accounts. Police were also finally granted warrants to access telephone records and were able to trace two calls, the one made by Lucy's customer to the Sasaki House payphone on the morning of her disappearance, and the call Lucy placed to her friend Louise from her customer's mobile phone on the afternoon she vanished. Both calls were traced to a mobile phone that had been purchased using a fake name. Further analysis of the phone records determined both calls were made from the Zushi Marina apartment complex.
The same location the American former hostess had identified as the building where she was drugged back in 1997 by a man she identified as Koji. Several other hostesses also identified the Zushi Marina as the location they were drugged and stripped naked, but none were able to remember the exact building or apartment number the incidents occurred. Police searched the criminal records of all apartment owners within the complex, looking for anyone who had a history of sexual offences. They made a startling discovery.
Forty-eight-year-old Joji Abara was a wealthy property developer and a business owner who had been arrested in 1998 for attempting to videotape unsuspecting women in public toilets. He pled guilty to the crime and was issued with a small fine. When police showed Joji's mugshot to the hostesses who had come forward claiming to have been drugged and assaulted, they unanimously identified Joji Abara as their attacker. Police obtained CCTV footage that revealed a luxury vehicle registered to Joji Abara had travelled to Tokyo on the day Lucy Blackman went missing. Police now felt confident they had identified their prime suspect, but needed concrete evidence
before they could make an arrest. Further investigation into Abara revealed he also owned a property in the Blue Sea apartment complex on the Mura Peninsula, a rugged coastline approximately 32 kilometres from Zushi. Five days after Lucy's disappearance, the apartment manager of the Blue Sea Building had phoned police to report one of his residents had been making unusual sounds in his apartment. Local police visited the apartment and found a shirtless Joji Abara dirty and covered in sweat with concrete residue on his hands.
He allowed the officers to enter his home, where they noticed chunks of cement was strewn about, along with a tool resembling a garden hoe and a sack containing a large item. Abara refused to let the officers inspect the rest of his apartment and as they had no warrant to proceed with a search, they left the property. At the time, Lucy Blackman's disappearance hadn't even made the news, so attending officers had no reason to be overly suspicious of Abara. But now that he had become their prime suspect in Lucy's abduction, this bizarre incident became highly suspicious.
Records revealed that Abara had recently purchased the boat, which stood out to investigators as unusual considering he had never owned one before and had no prior history of boating. Although there still wasn't enough evidence to arrest him in relation to Lucy Blackman's disappearance, investigators became increasingly nervous that he may use this new boat to dispose of evidence. On October 12th, police placed Joji Abara under arrest for five charges of rape for the reported assaults on other hostesses, intending to build their case against him for Lucy's abduction once he was in custody.
With Abara now under arrest, search warrants were granted for his many properties throughout Japan. At his largest property, a decaying, neglected mansion in the Denon Chofu district of southern Tokyo, police were confronted with a rubbish strewn yard containing several disused luxury cars, including a Maserati, a classic early 1960s Aston Martin, and a Bentley. The house held decades of accumulated clutter, broken televisions, old car batteries, and dust-covered furniture. A large freezer contained the frozen body of a dead dog, which Abara later explained had
been his favorite pet. He had frozen the body in the hopes that technological advancements would one day allow the dog to be restored to life or cloned. Included in piles of evidence seized from Abara's Denon Chofu mansion and other properties were piles of diaries, notebooks, documents, videotapes, rolls of film, audio cassettes, and photographs. The diaries and audio recordings dated all the way back to Abara's teenage years, outlining in meticulous detail his sexual fetishes, fantasies, and experiences in what he referred
to as conquest play. Abara's records revealed a prolific sexual predator. His method of assaulting women was always the same. He would pick up a hostess, or occasionally a woman who advertised in lonely hearts classified ads, and would then covertly administer some sort of tranquilizer within her food or drink. If the woman had concerns about the strange taste, he would explain the drink was rare or the food contained special herbs. Once the woman was rendered unconscious, he proceeded to rape her.
In one diary entry, Abara admitted he had no sexual interest in women who were conscious. His diaries detailed the various drugs he used to render women unconscious, along with a rating of their effectiveness. A dozen different types of drugs were recovered from his properties, including chloroform, sleeping pills, barbiturates, rehypnole, and a GHB. Joji Abara's prolific history as a violent sex offender was further evident within a large collection of videotapes dating back to the 1980s, many of which featured a woman 's name written along the spine.
The tapes were recorded using a tripod-mounted camera, with bright lights capturing the full extent of Abara's depraved attacks. Off camera, a television monitor displayed the assault so Abara could watch it as it was happening, while another played a pornographic film. On camera, a naked Abara wore a mask that matched that worn by the fictional character Zorro, a strip of black fabric with holes cut for the eyes, pulled across the upper face, and tied at the back of the head. He would carry his unconscious victim to bed before subjecting them to repeated acts of
sexual assault, with many attacks lasting upwards of 12 hours. In the event that a woman stirred or awoke during an assault, Abara would administer a chemical-soaked rag over their mouth to once again render them unconscious. When the woman awoke after the attack, feeling disoriented and sick, often vomiting and unable to stand, Abara would provide a vague explanation for how they came to pass out, including that there had been a gas leak, or that the woman drank too much alcohol. The exact number of videotapes recovered by police is uncertain, with reports ranging from 200 to 1,000.
With the recorded names and videotape footage, police identified both the American and Scottish women who had come forward during the Lucy Blackman investigation, and they were also able to chase many of the other survivors. Many of the women refused to cooperate with the investigation, preferring to forget their ordeal. However, several were willing to proceed with pressing charges. Despite uncovering a long list of women who had been violated by Georgie Abara, investigators were unable to find anything in his diaries or videotapes to confirm Lucy Blackman was
one of his victims. But they did find strands of long blonde hairs in the bathroom of Abara's sushi marina apartment. They were tested for DNA and came back with a match. The DNA sequence matched hairs taken from Lucy's Tokyo apartment and samples that had been provided by her family. Several rolls of film found on Abara's property were later developed and also provided concrete evidence that Lucy had entered his apartment. There, amongst the images, were two photographs of Lucy, smiling as she posed on the balcony
of his sushi marina apartment. Furthermore, the phone Lucy had used to call Louise Phillips on the day she went missing was also recovered, providing another direct link between Lucy and the accused. Receipts from multiple stores revealed that on July 4, just three days after Lucy vanished, Abara had purchased several suspicious items that would assist with the disposal of a body, including cement, large camping tarps, gloves, a shovel, an axe, and a chainsaw. Police now felt confident that Lucy had been drugged, assaulted, and subsequently murdered by Abara, but without locating her body, all they could prove was that the two had met.
In November 2000, one month after his initial arrest, Abara's lawyer issued a statement in which he denied any knowledge of Lucy Blackman's disappearance. He also insisted the assaults captured on video were consensual acts of conquest play, which each of the women had entered into voluntarily in exchange for money. Abara said he believed police had set him up, ending the statement with, I hope they catch the real criminal soon. In the United Kingdom, Lucy's family were provided with no information other than the fact that an arrest had been made.
They had to source information about Abara's predatory history and his many survivors from media reports rather than police. Lucy's father expressed his frustration in an email addressed to the Tokyo Metropolitan Police, reproduced in Richard Lloyd Perry's book, People Who Eat Darkness. Tim wrote, I am very upset and traumatised that the police do not give a single consideration to how the family feels as victims, and it is disgraceful and inhumane that you do not provide any news or information to the family to help them cope with this terrible and tragic event.
Tim blamed the fear of being deported for young hostesses not reporting crimes committed against them during their work duties, and questioned why the reports about Joji Abara from other hostesses had not been investigated in the past, quote. This makes the police guilty of the disappearance of Lucy, and when the next girl is abducted and raped or murdered, the police and the immigration department will be guilty of that crime too. As reports of Abara's disturbing crimes spread across the world, there was another family that had a strong reaction to the news.
In 1992, the family of 21-year-old Australian Corita Ridgway were left devastated when she died under mysterious circumstances while working in Tokyo. Corita, a model, waitress, and aspiring actor who had many friends, had moved to Tokyo in December of 1991 to join her sister Samantha for a working holiday, hoping to save some money for the acting classes she was attending back home in Sydney. She had also recently gotten engaged to her boyfriend Robert, and was eager to put some financial savings towards their life together. Having spent the last few years travelling to Nepal, Mexico, and the United States, Corita
was a worldly and confident traveller. In Japan, she intended to find a job teaching English, but when that plan wasn't immediately successful, she responded to a job ad in the newspaper for hostessing work at Club Ayakoji in the upmarket Ginza district, known for its exclusive restaurants and designer stores. Hostessing at Club Ayakoji involved the same task that Lucy Blackman had undertaken at Club Casablanca, chatting with customers whilst fetching their drinks and lighting their cigarettes. Although Corita didn't enjoy the work, she was making good money, and didn't expect to be doing it for long before she could return home with her savings.
On the night of Friday, February 14, 1992, Corita, along with several other Club Ayakoji hostesses, accepted an invitation from a customer to dine externally on a group douhan at a nearby restaurant. Corita's sister Samantha had spent that weekend out of town. When she returned to their share house on Sunday morning, another housemate informed Samantha that her sister wasn't at home. Someone had phoned the house and left a vague voice message saying Corita had gone away for the weekend with friends.
By Monday morning, Corita still hadn't returned home, and Samantha was becoming increasingly worried. She then received a phone call from the local hospital, explaining her sister had been admitted with severe food poisoning. A Japanese man calling himself Akira Nishida had dropped Corita off that morning, providing hospital staff with Samantha's phone number. According to Nishida, who left abruptly without providing any identification, Corita had developed food poisoning after eating bad shellfish.
Corita was non-responsive and slipping in and out of consciousness. She was diagnosed with acute liver failure, and by the time her mother Annette, father Nigel, and fiance Robert reached Japan, she was near unresponsive. Samantha attempted to communicate with her sister, but all Corita could manage was holding out her hand, wanting it to be held. The doctors were at a loss to explain how the 21-year-old had become so ill so quickly. They performed an expensive blood-washing liver procedure, but with no success. The toxins in Corita's body soon overwhelmed her system, turning her skin yellow.
Corita fell into a coma and was placed on life support, as her devastated family stood by and watched on helplessly. As Corita lay unresponsive in hospital, her sister Samantha received several calls from Akira Nishida, who provided the same story about Corita falling ill after eating shellfish. He refused to provide his phone number or address, so Samantha reported the phone calls to the police and urged them to investigate the caller. Two detectives eventually interviewed Samantha, who described her interaction with law enforcement as threatening and hostile, and felt no effort was made to find Akira Nishida.
In the hope that better facilities might improve her chances of survival, Corita was transferred to the Tokyo Women's University Hospital in Shinjuku, but pronounced brain dead shortly after her arrival. On Saturday, February 29, just three days before her 22nd birthday, Corita's family made the difficult decision to switch off her life support, with doctors ruling Hepatitis E as the cause of her death. Corita's body was dressed in a pink kimono and covered in flowers, before being taken to a Buddhist shrine in the hospital's basement, where the intensive care staff lit incense
sticks in her honour. Corita was cremated two days later. Traumatised from Corita's unexpected death, the Ridgway family made no request to have an autopsy conducted prior to the cremation. However, the small sample of her liver had been taken whilst the doctors were attempting to save her life, and was still retained on file by the hospital. Shortly after her sister's death, Samantha Ridgway was once again contacted by the man identifying himself as Akira Nishida.
When he learned that Corita had passed away, he insisted on meeting with her parents to offer his condolences and explain the events of their daughter's final weekend. Annette and Nigel Ridgway met Nishida in a hotel near the Tokyo airport. He was immaculately dressed, although sweating profusely, as he explained he had brought Corita back to his house after dinner as she had fallen ill from eating oysters. Her condition soon deteriorated, and he called a doctor to administer an injection for the nausea. When the injection didn't work, he drove her to hospital.
Annette and Nigel noted Nishida seemed desperate to convince them he had tried to care for their daughter. He expressed his intense affection for her, saying he loved Corita and had wanted to spend much more time with her. He presented Annette and Nigel with a diamond ring and gold necklace that he had planned to give to Corita for her birthday, and insisted on paying for her funeral, transferring the funds to Samantha's Japanese bank account. After this bizarre meeting, Corita's parents and fiancé Robert flew back to Australia
with Corita's ashes. There was no further investigation into her death. Then, nine years later, as reports of Joji Abara's crimes made their way into the Australian media, the Ridgways noticed chilling similarities to the circumstances of Corita's death. And when they saw a picture of Joji Abara, they immediately recognized him as the man who had introduced himself as Akira Nishida. Following this revelation, Corita's former fiancé Robert immediately contacted the Australian Embassy in Tokyo, who alerted police.
As it turned out, the Japanese authorities had already made the connection between Corita Ridgway and Joji Abara. Amongst piles of paperwork seized from Abara's sushi marina apartment was a receipt for Corita's hospital admission. Additionally, one of the videotapes from Abara's extensive collection featured an unconscious Corita as she was raped by Abara, during which he dosed her with a liquid soaked rag to ensure she remained unconscious. He detailed the assault in one of his diary entries, writing beside Corita's name,
Too Much Chloroform. The piece of Corita's liver that had been removed by doctors prior to her death in 1992 was recovered and tested. The sample was found to contain traces of chloroform, a highly volatile organic compound intended to be used for anesthetic purposes. Corita had been administered in excessive doses to drug poisons the liver and can lead to death. Although the presence of chloroform had not been tested or detected by doctors when Corita
was still alive, there was now no doubt that her death was due to chloroform poisoning. The funds that Samantha Ridgway had received to help pay for her sister's funeral were traced and led directly back to Joji Abara. In January 2001, Corita's mother Annette Ridgway travelled to Tokyo and formally identified Abara as Akira Nishida, the man she and her husband had met with following Corita's death. Abara admitted to posing as Akira Nishida and confessed to being with Corita the night she was hospitalized, though stuck by his story that he had tried to help her after she became ill, dropping her at the hospital out of genuine concern.
With the evidence indisputably linking Abara to Corita Ridgway's death, formal charges were laid against him for her murder. In January 2001, an intensive search for Lucy Blackman's body commenced throughout Abara's numerous properties. When the search proved fruitless, police concentrated on the beaches, caves and coastline around Abara's Blue Sea apartment building on the Mura Peninsula, where police had been called to investigate strange noises in the days following Lucy's disappearance. The area had already been searched following Abara's initial arrest, but this time the
search was much more extensive, employing the use of sniffer dogs and ground-penetrating radar. Only 180 metres from the Blue Sea apartment building was an isolated cliff hidden from view of the nearby houses. A portion of the cliff had eroded and collapsed, creating a small cave that could barely be seen to pass this by. On the morning of February 9, 2001, police discovered the cave and found an old rusted bathtub within, partially buried face down in the sand.
They dug it up and turned it over, finding a plastic bag buried in the sand underneath. There was no mistaking what the bag contained, human body parts. The dismembered body appeared to have been cut with a chainsaw, the skull then encased in cement. The exhumation took several hours, during which time the media learned of the discovery and quickly gathered at the scene. Police constructed a makeshift marquee around the cave entrance. The camera crews hovered above the shoreline in helicopters, and photographers boarded
fishermen's boats to get the best angles of the scene from the water. Lucy's family in the UK were not notified by Japanese police that a search was underway or that a body had been found, only learning of the discovery as it was broadcast on television. A post-mortem examination of the body compared the victim's teeth against Lucy's dental records, revealing a match. Seven months since she was last seen alive, Lucy Blackman had finally been found. The deterioration of her remains was so extensive that no cause of death could be officially determined.
After Lucy's remains were discovered, her family travelled back to Japan to bring her home. On March 19, 2001, almost a year since she first departed for Japan, a funeral was held for Lucy Blackman at St Nicholas Church in her hometown of Chiselhurst. More than 260 friends and family members attended the service, with a large media presence gathering outside. Inside the church, incense burnt alongside a framed photograph of a smiling Lucy, a gift from the Tokyo Metropolitan Police.
Prime Minister Tony Blair and the Japanese ambassador in London had flowers delivered to the service to express their condolences. Many mourners were moved to tears during a touching performance of the ballads wind beneath my wings and I will always love you. Reverend Charles Walker told the congregation, Lucy was a glorious girl who could light up a room with her presence, her vitality, sense of life and fun, her laughing face, her warm heart and concern for others. He read from a letter sent by a Japanese family who had lost their daughter while she was
travelling in Europe. They had been praying that Lucy would be found alive and well, and stated, We are so ashamed of ourselves as a nation. Outside the church, Lucy's mother Jane Stier told a journalist, I am pained by the thought of what happened to Lucy before she was killed. She was a tragic victim of a perverted psychopath and I cannot get the terrible thought of how she may have suffered out of my mind. As a mother, I hope her death was painless and that she would have felt no fear.
On April 6, 2001, whilst in custody for the other allegations against him, Joji Obara was formally arrested for Lucy Blackman's murder. His trial commenced three months later on July 4, 2001, where the public got their first inside into the accused. Obara was born to Korean immigrants in the Japanese city of Osaka in 1952. Although his parents were poor when they arrived in Japan, his father gradually built a fortune investing in taxis, car parks, poker machines and property, ensuring Obara lived a privileged life.
He attended an exclusive prep school in Tokyo before moving on to the prestigious K.O. University, where his father purchased him the Denon Chofu mansion and hired a maid to take care of him while he completed his studies. When Obara was 17 years old, his father died in Hong Kong during an overseas business trip, which many speculated was at the hands of the Yakuza, with whom he was said to have business dealings. His vast fortune was passed on to his children and widow, and Obara became incredibly wealthy. After receiving his inheritance, Obara travelled internationally for several years before obtaining
degrees in politics and law. He lived lavishly in Tokyo and also purchased multiple properties all over the country, which increased in value during Japan's bubble economy of the mid-1980s, leading him to form an investment company and purchase several property development businesses. He frequently drove his luxury cars to high-end hostess clubs, where he spent large sums of money to secure the company of Western hostesses, who served as a status symbol. It was during this time that he established his sexually predatory behaviour and began keeping records of the women he assaulted.
When the economic bubble burst and the Japanese economy collapsed in the early 1990s, Obara's investment company folded and many of his assets were decimated. He was pursued by multiple creditors and reportedly used one of his companies as a front for Yakuza money laundering operations to stay afloat financially. By 1999, Obara was being sued for unpaid loans, yet he still owned multiple companies and several residential properties. This allowed him to continue his lavish lifestyle where he frequently spent large amounts of time and money at hostess bars, living a mostly nocturnal existence cruising back and
forth between his coastal and central Tokyo apartments. Obara had an apparent dislike for his own physical appearance. He reportedly underwent extensive cosmetic eye surgery to make his eyes appear more westernised and wore shoe lifts to disguise his five-foot, five-inch height. He also took regular doses of human growth hormones, large quantities of which were found on his properties during police searches following his arrest. He avoided cameras his whole life, refusing to be photographed wherever possible. Very few photos existed of Obara where he was not intentionally looking away from the
camera or wearing sunglasses. And in his police mugshot, he kept his eyes cast to the ground. As Obara's trial commenced, he faced charges for abduction, eight cases of rape, and rape resulting in death for Lucy Blackman and Corita Ridgway. In the Japanese legal system, the charge of rape resulting in death is similar to manslaughter in that it doesn't carry the full weight of a murder charge. Obara's parents are also invited to respond to the charges against them with a statement as opposed to a simple plea of guilty or not guilty.
In Obara's statement, he denied being responsible for the death of either woman, alleging he and Corita Ridgway had engaged in consensual sexual relations and that he had tried to save her by dropping her at the hospital after she became ill. He alleged Lucy Blackman had invited herself to his apartment, where she had tried to pursue him. They drank alcohol and watched television together, but didn't engage in any conquest play, nor did he administer her any drugs without her knowledge. According to Obara, Lucy left his apartment the next morning, alive and well.
In the indictment for Lucy's death, the prosecution put forward that on Saturday, July 1, 2000, Obara had invited Lucy to his sushi marina apartment, where he provided her with a drink laced with sleeping pills before using chloroform to render her unconscious. He then raped her, and at some point during or after the assault, she passed away due to a fatal overdose of the drugs he had administered. Two days later, Obara called Louise Phillips and provided a fictional story about Lucy joining a cult to halt an investigation into her disappearance and deflect any suspicion from himself. On Tuesday, July 4, he went to a hardware store to purchase a variety of materials,
including hammers, cutters, sleeping bags, tents, a shovel, a chainsaw, cement, and a chemical agent that speeds up the setting process of cement. The next day, he drove to his Blue Sea apartment on the Mura Peninsula, where he dismembered Lucy's body with a chainsaw, covered her head in cement, put her limbs into plastic bags, and buried her remains in the cave, covering them with the bathtub. A neighbour had seen him on the beach carrying a shovel, while a tent uncovered from the cave matched the one Obara had purchased. The marks on Lucy's bones were found to be consistent with the same type of chainsaw
he had bought. Despite the overwhelming amount of circumstantial evidence against him, in the Japanese justice system, everything must be proven through concrete evidence before a connection can be drawn between one event and the next. For example, just because Obara purchased a particular-making model of a chainsaw that matched the marks found on Lucy's body, it doesn't prove without doubt that he was the one who killed her. Due to the deteriorated condition of Lucy's remains and the fact that no evidence was
found of her being sexually assaulted amongst Obara's possessions, no one questionable physical link was established to prove without doubt that Obara murdered Lucy. In a situation where the accused denies any wrongdoing, Japanese criminal trials can be exhaustive. In 2001, Japan was not using a jury system, and the court hearings did not run over a continuous period. Instead, Joji Obara's trial was overseen by a panel of judges over a series of monthly hearings that continued for several years, with the trial held up further when Obara's
initial legal team resigned after the first year. As the prosecution strived to prove every aspect of the indictment, the defense exploited the lack of physical evidence. They argued that not a single trace of Lucy's blood had been found anywhere at Obara's apartments, rendering the notion that he had dismembered her body with a chainsaw as highly unlikely. When Obara eventually took the stand for Lucy's death, he outraged her family by alleging she had willingly consumed a large amount of recreational drugs and alcohol, leading to
最初的法律团队在第一年结束后辞职了。随着控方努力证明起诉书的各个方面，辩方则利用缺乏物证这一点进行反击。他们辩称，在小原的公寓里没有找到任何一丝露西的血迹，这使得他用电锯分尸的说法变得极不可能。当小原最终就露西的死出庭作证时，他声称露西是自愿服用了大量的娱乐性毒品和酒精，从而导致了
an overdose. He claimed he had contacted a distant acquaintance, who had since passed away, to take Lucy to the hospital, and he didn't know what happened to her after that. He explained he purchased the chainsaw and other tools used for dismemberment with the intention to dispose of the body of his beloved pet dog, the one police had found frozen inside his Denon Chofu mansion. A few days after Lucy's overdose, he spent the night walking around looking for a place to dispose of his dog's body, but was bitten extensively by bugs, forcing him to cancel
药物过量，这激怒了露西的家属。他声称自己曾联系过一个远方熟人——此人后来已经去世——将露西送往医院，而此后发生了什么他便不得而知了。他解释说，他购买电锯和其他分尸工具的初衷是为了处理他深爱的宠物狗的遗体，也就是警察在他位于调布市丹顿的豪宅里发现的那只被冻住的狗。在露西因服药过量身亡几天后，他曾花了一夜时间到处寻找可以掩埋狗尸的地方，但却被虫子狠狠地咬了，这迫使他取消了
his plans. Hospital records confirmed he did indeed seek medical treatment for bug bites. For the charges relating to Corita Ridgway, Obara's defense maintained the conquest play between their client and the deceased had been consensual. They argued that the video where Corita was unconscious had been filmed months prior to her death during an established consensual relationship. On the night of her death, they engaged in consensual sex before Corita fell ill, and Obara did everything he could to ensure she received medical care.
他的计划。医院记录证实，他确实曾因虫咬去寻求过医疗救治。对于针对科里塔·里奇韦的指控，小原的辩护律师坚称，他们的当事人与死者之间的“征服游戏”是双方自愿的。他们辩称，科里塔失去知觉的视频是在她死前几个月两人建立的自愿关系期间拍摄的。在她去世当晚，两人在科里塔身体不适之前发生了自愿性行为，并且小原尽其所能确保她得到了医疗护理。
The trial dragged on for several years, during which Obara turned his cell into a makeshift illegal office. He had a team of 10 lawyers working for him in relation to the criminal trial and further litigation involving debts owed to creditors across his various companies. During this time, Obara was declared bankrupt, with debts exceeding 23.8 billion yen, the equivalent to approximately 200 million Australian dollars. The only visitors Obara received during his incarceration were his mother and his lawyers. He was well behaved, with one guard commenting,
审判拖延了好几年，在此期间，小原将他的牢房改造成了一个临时非法办公室。他有一个由10名律师组成的团队为他工作，处理刑事审判以及与其各家公司债权人债务相关的进一步诉讼。在此期间，小原被宣布破产，债务超过238亿日元，相当于大约2.07亿澳元。小原在服刑期间接待的唯一访客只有他的母亲和他的律师。他表现良好，一名看守评论说：
My impression is that he is totally sane. There's nothing crazy about him except the way he treats women. He's very, very clever, but very selfish, totally convinced that he is right, and he never listens to the opinions of other people. He is a very lonely person. When Lucy's father, Tim Blackman, saw Obara in court for the first time, he too was struck by Obara's sense of loneliness, later commenting, I see somebody who is the same age as me, who has, by his actions, produced the most
“我的印象是他完全正常。他除了对待女性的方式之外，没有什么疯狂的地方。他非常非常聪明，但也极其自私，坚信自己是正确的，从不听取别人的意见。他是一个非常孤独的人。”当露西的父亲蒂姆·布莱克曼第一次在法庭上看到小原时，他也对小原那种孤独感触动很深，后来评论道：“我看到一个和我同龄的人，由于他的行为，给自己的生活造成了最
terrible situation for himself by doing something so heinous to somebody else's life. And in a very strange way, there's a pathos that neutralises the more natural anger. I feel sorry for him. In April 2006, as Obara's trial entered its fifth year, Lucy's mother Jane, father Tim and Carita Ridgway's mother Annette provided evidence similar to a victim impact statement. They each expressed the emotional suffering and life-changing trauma caused by the deaths of their daughters, with Tim Blackman telling the court of the devastating effects Lucy's death had on her sister Sophie, who had since attempted self-harm.
可怕的困境，因为他对别人的生命做出了如此残忍的事。以一种非常奇怪的方式，有一种悲凉感冲淡了更自然的愤怒。我为他感到遗憾。”2006年4月，随着小原的审判进入第五年，露西的母亲简、父亲蒂姆以及卡里塔·里奇韦的母亲安妮特提供了类似于受害者影响陈述的证词。他们各自表达了女儿们的死所带来的情感痛苦和改变生活的人生创伤，蒂姆·布莱克曼向法庭讲述了露西的死对她妹妹苏菲造成的毁灭性打击，苏菲此后曾试图自残。
Obara, who had studiously attended every hearing beforehand to take comprehensive notes, refused to leave his cell on the days when the families were speaking, wedging himself into a small crevice so he could not be physically removed by the guards. As the trial continued, Lucy's parents were contacted individually by an associate of Obara's who wanted to discuss the possibility of an atonement payment. Based on the Japanese honour system, this kind of payment is offered following a wrongdoing to avoid dishonour being brought upon the wrongdoer's family. It typically occurs when the party offering the payment admits guilt.
小原此前一直在认真出席每一场听证会并做全面笔记，但在家属发言的日子里，他拒绝离开牢房，把自己塞进一个小缝隙里，这样看守就无法把他强行带走。随着审判的继续，露西的父母分别被小原的一位同伙联系，对方想要讨论支付“赎罪金”的可能性。根据日本的荣誉系统，这种支付通常是在发生错误行为后提供的，以避免给肇事者家庭带来耻辱。这通常发生在提供赔偿的一方承认有罪的时候。
However, in this case, Obara was admitting no guilt or responsibility for Lucy's death, but offered the financial compensation as an expression of his condolences. Whilst Lucy's mother Jane turned the payment down, unbeknownst to her, her ex-husband accepted. 100 million yen, approximately 1.2 million Australian dollars in today's currency, would be paid to Tim Blackman on the condition he signed a document written in poorly phrased English, which called into question the cause of Lucy's death as alleged by the prosecution. Thinking the risk of jeopardising the case was negligible, Tim recognised the money would benefit his family and be vital in the ongoing running of the Lucy Blackman Trust, a not-for-profit
然而在本案中，小原并没有承认对露西的死负有任何罪责或责任，而是作为慰问的表达提供了经济赔偿。虽然露西的母亲简拒绝了这笔钱，但在她不知情的情况下，她的前夫接受了。100万日元（按今天的汇率约合120万澳元）将支付给蒂姆·布莱克曼，条件是他签署了一份用语拙劣的英文文件，该文件对检方指控的露西死因提出了质疑。蒂姆认为危及案件的风险微乎其微，并认识到这笔钱将对他的家庭有利，对持续运营“露西·布莱克曼信托基金”至关重要，这是一个非营利组织，
organisation he had established to help young people be more aware of their safety when travelling overseas. He accepted the payment and signed the document, stating, to me it was just a meaningless piece of paper. Lucy's body was so decomposed, none of us knew the cause of death for certain. After signing it, Tim wrote a letter to the prosecution, categorically stating he believed Obara was guilty of all charges and that accepting the money in no way signified any forgiveness towards the accused.
由他建立，旨在帮助年轻人提高在海外旅行时的安全意识。他接受了这笔款项并签署了文件，并表示：“对我来说，这只是一张毫无意义的纸。露西的尸体已经高度腐烂，我们谁也不知道确切的死因。”签署后，蒂姆写信给检方，明确表示他相信小原对所有指控负有罪行，接受这笔钱绝不意味着对被告有任何宽恕。
Corita Ridgway's family were also offered a similar payment, but turned it down. Sophie Blackman supported her father's decision to accept the money, stating, Dad used that money to pay back his family who gave us thousands of pounds so that we could afford to fly back and forth to Japan over the last seven years. He has also put a lot of it into the Lucy Blackman Trust, which we set up in memory of Lucy. During this emotionally exhausting period of public scrutiny, Joji Obara's trial, which had now been in the courts for six years, finally drew to a conclusion.
科里塔·里奇韦的家属也收到了类似的赔偿提议，但被拒绝了。苏菲·布莱克曼支持她父亲接受这笔钱的决定，并表示：“爸爸用这笔钱偿还了家人的债务，他们给了我们数千英镑，使我们能够负担得起过去七年里飞往日本的往返机票。他还把很多钱投入了我们为纪念露西而设立的露西·布莱克曼信托基金。”在这段饱受公众审视、情感筋疲力尽的时期里，已经在法庭上审理了六年的乔治·小原的审判终于迎来了尾声。
On April 24, 2007, a crowd gathered in the public gallery of the Tokyo District Court has judged Satomu Tochigi delivered the unanimous verdict reached by himself and the two other judges presiding over the case. For the rape leading to death of Corita Ridgway and to the rapes of eight other women, Judge Tochigi declared Joji Obara guilty and imposed a life sentence, telling him, quote, He treated these women as sexual objects to satisfy your last. One opinion might be that these women were careless, but I believe that they could not anticipate your deviant behaviour.
2007年4月24日，东京地方法院的旁听席上挤满了人群，主审法官栃木力宣读了他与审判本案的其他两名法官达成的一致裁决。因强奸致死科里塔·里奇韦以及强奸另外八名女性的罪名，栃木法官宣布乔治·小原罪名成立，并判处无期徒刑，对他说：“你把这些女性当作满足你欲望的性对象。一种观点可能是这些女性不够谨慎，但我认为她们无法预料到你变态的行为。”
You repeated the same routine over eight years, treating their lives and their bodies carelessly. It is rooted in your self-centered attitude. You have trampled on the dignity of women. Judge Tochigi then shocked the courtroom by announcing Obara was acquitted of the charges relating to Lucy Blackman's death, citing a lack of evidence linking him to Lucy's murder and the disposal of her body. Judge Tochigi said while it was clear that Lucy had been with Obara prior to her death, the prosecution had not been able to prove without doubt that he was responsible.
“你在八年里重复着同样的日常，对她们的生命和身体草率以待。这根源于你以自我为中心的态度。你践失了女性的尊严。”随后，栃木法官宣布小原被判无罪，这震惊了法庭，法官指出缺乏将他与露西·布莱克曼的谋杀及抛尸联系起来的证据。栃木法官表示，虽然很明显露西在死前曾与小原在一起，但控方未能毫无合理怀疑地证明他是罪魁祸首。
Judge Tochigi made particular reference to the lack of evidence around the circumstances in which her body had been moved from the site of her death to the cave where she was buried. For these reasons, the court was unable to fully discount the possibility that someone else was involved. They made it clear the document signed by Tim Blackman for the condolence payment had nothing to do with the acquittal. Lucy's family was devastated by the verdict.
栃木法官特别提到了缺乏关于其尸体如何从死亡地点转移到她被埋葬的洞穴的周围环境的证据。出于这些原因，法院无法完全排除其他人参与的可能性。他们明确指出，蒂姆·布莱克曼为慰问金签署的文件与无罪释放无关。露西的家属对这一裁决感到崩溃。
In a subsequent press conference, Tim Blackman said, I'm afraid to say the lack of justice for us today has been the failure of the prosecution team to develop the case adequately. There is nothing that will change that Lucy is dead, but in many respects Lucy has been robbed of her justice. We believe our family deserves to get proper justice for Lucy and that prosecutors should strongly consider an appeal. Lucy's mother, Jane Stee, said, I'm heartbroken, absolutely heartbroken.
在随后的新闻发布会上，蒂姆·布莱克曼说：“我遗憾地说，我们今天未能获得正义，是由于控方团队未能充分展开案件。没有什么能改变露西已经死亡的事实，但在许多方面，露西被剥夺了她的正义。我们认为我们的家庭理应为露西讨回真正的正义，检方应该强烈考虑上诉。”露西的母亲简·斯蒂说：“我心碎了，彻底心碎了。”
I just can't believe this verdict. My worst fears have come true. The Ridgway family stated they found comfort in Obara's life sentence, as it ensured he would no longer be able to harm innocent people. Both the defense and the prosecution appealed the verdict, with the defense maintaining Obara's innocence on all charges, and to the prosecution seeking another opportunity to convict him for Lucy Blackman's death. After the appeal hearing in 2008, presiding judge Hiroshi Cardano ruled that Joji Obara
“我简直不敢相信这个判决。我最担忧的事情成真了。”里奇韦家族表示，他们从小原的无期徒刑中得到了一些安慰，因为这确保了他将无法再伤害无辜的人。辩方和控方都对判决提出了上诉，辩方坚持小原对所有指控无罪，而控方则寻求另一个机会以露西·布莱克曼之死为由为他定罪。在2008年的上诉听证会后，主审法官卡诺弘裁定乔治·小原
was guilty of kidnapping Lucy with the intention of drugging and raping her, before dismembering her body at his sushi marina apartment. However, due to the lack of physical evidence, he upheld the finding of the original trial that declared Obara not guilty for causing Lucy's death. Judge Cardano, quote, the court recognizes that the defendant is responsible for damaging and abandoning the body. His action was ruthless, and did not even give the slightest consideration to her dignity. The court believes the defendant kidnapped her with the intention of drugging and raping
犯有绑架露西并意图下药强奸她的罪行，之后在其实寿司码头公寓将她的尸体分尸。然而，由于缺乏物证，他维持了初审中宣布小原不对露西的死负责的无罪裁决。卡诺法官表示：“法院承认被告对损坏和遗弃尸体负有责任。他的行为极其残忍，甚至没有对她的尊严给予丝毫尊重。法院认为被告绑架她是出于下药和强奸的意图，”
her, but the court could not prove he made her pass out by using chloroform, or that he carried out his intentions. Judge Cardano upheld Obara's life sentence, and ruled out the possibility of any further appeals. While the ruling didn't provide Lucy's family with the outcome they hoped for, Tim Blackman told the press that Obara is now starting a life sentence for his terrible crimes against the women over many decades, and that it was Lucy who finally brought him to justice. Lucy's a satisfactory overall result, and I feel justice has finally been served.
“但法院无法证明他通过使用氯仿使她昏迷，也无法证明他付诸实施了意图。”卡诺法官维持了小原的无期徒刑，并排除了进一步上诉的可能性。虽然这一裁决并没有给露西的家属带来他们所希望的结果，但蒂姆·布莱克曼对媒体表示，小原现在正为他对多十年间女性犯下的可怕罪行开始服无期徒刑，正是露西最终将他绳之以法。露西是一个令人满意的总体结果，我觉得正义终于得到了伸张。
Lucy's travel companion and best friend, Louise Phillips, struggled in the years following Lucy's death, tormented by guilt. In an interview with journalist Richard Boyd-Parrie for his book People Who Eat Darkness, she described the crushing weight of Lucy's death as ever present, quote, I felt guilty on my wedding day, so guilty that I was getting married and she wasn't. I felt guilty for being happy, guilty for getting older. It seemed like it was my fault that I was here, and she wasn't. In 2011, Carita Ridgway's mother, Renette, broke her decades-long silence about the
露西的旅行同伴兼最好朋友路易丝·菲利普斯在露西死后的几年里苦苦挣扎，饱受内疚的折磨。在接受记者理查德·博伊德-帕里为其书《吃黑暗的人》采访时，她将露西之死带来的沉重负担描述为无处不在：“我在婚礼那天感到内疚，内疚于我要结婚而她没有。我为自己感到快乐而内疚，为自己变老而内疚。似乎我在这里而她不在是我的错。”2011年，卡里塔·里奇韦的母亲雷内特打破了她长达数十年的沉默，
death of her daughter in an interview with Australian magazine, Women's Weekly. During the interview, Renette candidly spoke of her fear that Obara would allude justice, calling the convicted killer a beast with a human face. Renette thinks about her daughter often, quote, I try to be happy, I know Carita would want that, I miss her smile, so I cling to that and try to be as happy as I can, but it's not easy. Carita had her life stretching out before her, and then it just stopped. I lost my daughter and everything we'd ever share with her.
在接受澳大利亚杂志《女性周刊》采访时谈到了她女儿的死。在采访中，雷内特坦率地谈到了她对小原逃脱法律制裁的恐惧，称这个被定罪的杀手为“有人面兽心的野兽”。雷内特经常想起她的女儿：“我努力保持快乐，我知道卡里塔会希望这样的，我怀念她的微笑，所以我紧紧抓住这一点，尽量让自己快乐，但这并不容易。卡里塔的人生本该有大好的前程，但它就这样戛然而止了。我失去了女儿以及我们与她共度的所有一切。”
I'll never know the grandchildren she might have had. Her future disappeared because one man wanted to satisfy some weird sexual urge. There's no closure, not for me. I won't have closure until that man is dead, but even then, I'm not sure that will help. Nothing can bring Carita back. In the end, that's all you're left with, that immeasurable loss. The Lucy Blackman Trust is still in operation today, providing support to British nationals in crisis overseas.
“我永远不会知道她可能生下的孙子孙女。她的未来消失了，只因为一个男人想要满足某种奇怪的性冲动。没有解脱，对我来说没有。除非那个男人死了，否则我不会得到解脱，但即便如此，我也不确定那是否有用。没有什么能让卡里塔回来。最后，你所剩下的只有那种无法估量的失落。”露西·布莱克曼信托基金至今仍在运营，为身处海外危机的英国国民提供支持。
The organisation helps those dealing with death, abduction, sexual assault, incidents of serious crime and missing person cases, and has assisted thousands of families facing international law deals. Tim Blackman is currently in the process of raising funds for a project titled Lucy's Retreat, which aims to provide a safe, peaceful setting for the families of missing people abroad to take respite and to receive support. The retreat will offer therapy, logistical problem-solving, live link-ups between courtrooms in the UK and around the world, satellite news channels, and feature a memorial garden
该组织帮助那些应对死亡、绑架、性侵犯、严重刑事犯罪和失踪人员案件的人，并协助了成千上万个面临国际法律交易的家庭。蒂姆·布莱克曼目前正在为一个名为“露西的庇护所”的项目筹集资金，该项目旨在为海外失踪人员的家属提供一个安全、宁静的环境来休养并获得支持。该庇护所将提供治疗、逻辑问题解决、英国与世界各地法庭之间的实时直播连线、卫星新闻频道，并设有纪念花园，
where visitors are invited to create a peace in memory of their loved ones that can be revisited over time. In August of 2018, as what would have been Lucy's 40th birthday approached, Tim Blackman reflected on what his daughter's life might have been like if she was still alive. He is convinced his bubbly and ambitious daughter would have built a successful career for herself and be raising a family of her own. Tim Blackman quote, Every day you think about what she'd be doing now, whether she would be married, whether
访客可以在那里创造一件纪念他们所爱之人的工艺品，供日后重访。2018年8月，随着本应是露西40岁生日的临近，蒂姆·布莱克曼反思了如果女儿还活着，她的人生会是什么样子。他坚信自己那个活泼且有雄心的女儿本会为自己建立成功的事业并组建自己的家庭。蒂姆·布莱克曼说：“每天你都在想她现在在做什么，她是否结婚了，是否
I'd have grandchildren by her. It leaves a constant chasm of emptiness when you lose someone young like that. You hear this word closure, but it just doesn't exist in these sorts of cases. The notion that you just shut the door on that part of your life just doesn't happen. As a father, you don't want to put that burden down. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我会由她生下孙子孙女。当你失去这样一个年轻的生命时，会留下一道持续空虚的鸿沟。你听过‘解脱’这个词，但在这种案件中它根本不存在。你只是把生活的那一部分关上门的想法根本不会发生。作为父亲，你不想放下那个负担。”本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。